what if I triple it up you did double
condom no Joe did why would you ever do
why did you do double Concepts wait
you've actually worn two you're not even
gonna feel anything anymore
you already don't feel anything now
you're nothing for anything there's like
a sermon yeah yeah what part's trying to
say is don't wear condoms out there
right yeah yes and it said like ultra
thin for sensitive I'll see if it's true
hey you still wear condoms yeah yeah Dan
don't be all judge just pull out dude
that's not fun no I pull in you leave it
in what when I go this is dangerous and
then I put on a condom and then I bust
inside okay that's the ritual every time
you have sex you have to say this is
dangerous or sometimes I go push it to
the limit it is crazy to see how many of
those dudes like have sex with random
chicks with no condoms I know how many
of them just leave it in bro they are a
lot of winners comments oh I actually
did that a couple times while the women
already disclosing that they're on birth
control no no I don't speak the same
language